en poste année 90 ça va être la folie et
malorine natf sera avec nous pour un
témoignage un témoignage de fou je vous
le dis tout de suite parce que ça a été
une des plus grandes stars des années 90
elle va nous raconter sa descente aux
enfers elle sera accompagné de Jean-Luc
azoulet ça va être très très très très
fort ça pour le moment on est avec Jean
Jean le médium bonsoir jeanide bonsoir
merci d'être
là on va on
va alors jeandide
bonsoir
JIDE vous avez vous avez préparé parce
que on va parler de l'année 2024 qui
arrive à grand pas vous avez préparé une
une pyramide de de gu j'ai fait une un
petit tirage live on va dire d'ord sur
quoi c'est sur l'année ça ça c'est sur
l'année pour voir il y a une carte que
vous avezné particuli la
mort présente sur ce tirage j'ai pas
fait exprès hein non c'est vrai ah ouais
quand vous avez tiré c'est pour c'est
pour ce qui va se passer dans c'est pour
ce qui va se passer sur l'année donc on
voit que la première carte c'est une
bonne carte puis que c'est la meilleure
carte du jeu le monde le monde nous qume
chose faut savoir que l'année 2004 en
numérologie ça fait 8 quand on
additionne l'année 2024 ça fait 8 2 + 2
4 4 + 4 8 c'est donc voilà 8 c'est aussi
tout ce qui est en rapport avec la
justice avec la loi donc il peut se
passer aussi beaucoup de choses autour
de la loi il peut y avoir par exemple
encore des procès avec des hommes de
politique par exemple avec des des
affaires qui vont ressortir il faut pas
oublier que le 8 quand on le c'est la
voilà et voilà quand on le couche c'est
l'infini donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que c'est une année qui est très
ouverte avec deux choses qui vont vers
l'infini et qui peuvent aussi nous
réserver des surprises par exemple sur
le plan euh astrologique mais aussi sur
le plan astronomique parce que on peut
découvrir des nouvelles planètes ou des
nouvelles civilisations peut-être des
extraterrestres ça fait quelques temps
qu'on parle qu'on va peut-être être en
contact avec des extraterrestres ça peut
êre peut-être par contre effectivement
pourquoi pas en 2024 où il peut y avoir
ce contact avec pourquoi pourquoi la
mort alors la mort c'est un peu la même
chose que le 8 et l'infini c'est-à-dire
que c'est une transformation quand on
voit cette carte on voit qu'il y a un
épis de blé sur le personnage qu'on
appelle son nom manger beaucoup de on
l'appelle l'arcain son nom et en fin de
compte c'est le cycle de la vie
c'est-à-dire qu'on s'èime on récolte et
on recoupe le blé et on recommence donc
voilà c'est pas spécialement toujours
quelque chose qui est
principalement sur la mort en
particulier mais bon cette car quand on
tire cette carte on n'est pas comme des
oufs non plus hein non plus parce que à
côté il y a le diable le diable ça veut
dire qui va avec la spiritualé di un
drôle de gueule c'est les cartes du
Tarot de Marseille comm ça donc
au-dessus on a le pape qui représente
lui la spiritualité et les religions en
particulier c'est le PAP c'est le pape
normal c'est pas le papeouf voà non
c'est c'est le pape pas le pape non
d'accord
donc par rapport à ça on peut se dire
qu'il peut y avoir aussi encore à
nouveau malheureusement des conflits de
religion ça c'est qui c'est qui ça l
parce que ça c'est las ça c'est leOM
c'est un un personnage qui prend son
petit balluchon et qui va qui s'en va
qui on parle de toi
Gill donc voilà dans les cartes donc ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que là il
peut y avoir des conflits de religion il
peut y avoir encore des des actes
terroristes tu en train de N dire 2024
ça être la merde quoi c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure un peu au
début une espèce de Contin
ette cette transformation qui est
effectivement puisque on a l'arcom qui
nous annonce qu'on va changer de cycle
c'est ce qu'on disait on va on va se
transformer on va aller de toute façon
vers des choses même s'il y a des
combats un peu spirituels on va aller
vers ce monde spirituel faut
pas comment dire oublier non plus qu'il
y a des choses qui se passent dans le
cosmos cette année avec par exemple la
planète Pluton qui est une planète
importante plus une planète elle va
rentrer ils l'ont arrêté ah oui pourquoi
c'est Pluton c'est plus une planète he
il y a y a que H planètes dans le
Système solaire il d'corddant pour un
médium en tout cas
nous pour les astrologues et pour les
médiums on considère qu'elle existe
toujours asrologie elle est petite mais
elle existe toujours donc elle a
toujours un rôle fondamental à jouer et
elle va changer de signe puisquelle va
rentrer dans le Verseau et on est du
Verseau donc ça veut dire que en en
résumé donc c'est c'est c'est voilà
c'est est-ce qu'on peut est-ce que je
peux tirer une
carteou on va enlever celleci je vais
tirer une carte et on va il faut qu'il
pose une question ou c'est comme ça
question alors je vrais tirer une carte
déjà pour un un ou deux chroniqueurs qui
qui
m'intéressent je voudrais tirer une
carte pour Géraldine c'est vous qui l'a
tiré pour moi c'est moi qui l' tire pour
vous et après moi je vais rajouter les
cartes dessus he ah d'accord ah oui d'
c'est pour Géraldine pour Géraldine une
carte va voir ton émission la
mort
la maison de la Maison La Maison Dieu
c'est ce qu'on appelle la maison de Dieu
on jamais vu cette carte ces non on l'
jamais vu même ououi c'est là c'est
pareil c'est ça c'est une carte de
transformation et de changement ça veut
dire que les bases sur lesquelles vous
travaillez aujourd'hui sont des bases
qui sont à changer à modifier et à
restructurer parce que vous avez pas des
bonnes bases sur ce que vous faites mais
par contre vous êtes quelqu'un qui a
envie d'aller de l'avant et de
travailler donc vous allez le faire au
cours de l'année il y a des choses qui
vont se passer de manière importante
surtout au déclic de l'intuition de la
sensibilité comme si quelque chose ou
des événements qui se sont peut-être
déjà passés autour de vous avaient fait
que vous étiez un petit peu à flur de
peau avec des personnes de votre
entourageroyable fleur de peau ouais
franchement c'est incroyable je ouais je
rentrerai pas dans les détails mais
c'est incroyable ouf c'est exactement ça
jeanit tu es trop fort fleur de peau la
fleur de un quelque chose qui s'est
passé dans mon entourage qui m'a
forcément fragilisé effectivement ça va
avir des répercussion
20 non parce que je suis pique attends
j'aurais pu arranger
çapz développer une certaine forme
d'intuition parce que j'ai l'impression
que vous faisiez pas trop confiance à
votre intuition jus pr et maintenant du
coup avec ce qui est en train de se
passer autour de vous vous allez vous
ouvrir un peu plus et faire un peu
[Applaudissements]
plus Mo non toi c'est bon l'utre fois on
pas fait déjà vas-y je te ti la ah super
allez
chômage et la
question la justice on fait
pas pas fa pas il a l'ermite en
plus la justice c'est la carte numéro 8
justement c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure c'est la carte qui est en
rapport avec cette année en l'année 2024
l'année la carte qui représente aussi
l'infini par que c infini va vous
apporter aussi une transformation un
changement et de choses extrêmement
positives pour vous par contre ça
fait quelques temps que vous êtes en
train de mûir sur des changements
peut-être au niveau
professionnel et des changements qui
pourraient aboutir aussi au cours de
l'année prochaine c'est vrai en plus
c'est vrai il est très fort est très
fort franchement je vous jure que c'est
vra parce qu' il y a quoi il y a que
vous et tous les deux vous êtes au
courant et nous on pas au courant ér ou
profnel bravo incro génial donc ça veut
dire qu'en plus ça va marcher cette
transformation ce changement va arriver
par contre il y a des choses qui peuvent
se passer à l'international aussi
[Applaudissements]
c'estàdireit
sarrêter je parle pas du professionnel
je parle
de les
vacances pour pour
voyager voyages on va aller demand
attend je demande après moi ça
allez la mort non et le diable
ah comme par hasard diable oh là là oh
là là là oh ça sent mauvais ça oh ça
sent pas bon non c'est pas si maais ça
en fin de compte il faut savoir que
alors le le diable ça représente aussi
l'orgueil ça représente aussi la
sensualité la sexualité arrête un peu
dit ça Daniel
te c'est c'est des choses qui sont très
présentes par rapport à ça mais il y a
par contre une transformation et un
changement professionnel alors moi par
contre je vois pas trop rester ici ah oh
bar-toi bar-toi sérieux je pense qu'il
va y avoir autre chose qui va vous
appeler parce que là vous bougez vous
partez et vous avez un projet qu'on va
vous proposer qui va être aussi
intéressant pour vous ça va être mieux
ou moins bien alors vous reviendrez
certainement ici parce que vous serez
pas s sans revenir mais par contre tout
ce qui est en rapport avec le
professionnel beaucoup d'importance pour
vous et surtout sur des des emplois
nouveaux où vous allez mettre beaucoup
de magnétisme aussi dans ce que vous
allez faire et dans ce que vous allevez
présenté les contacts c'est pour le
début de l'année prochaine donc ça va V
début de l'année prochaine ah ou pour
revenir revenir ok très bien on va très
bien donc tu vois ça bouge he pour toi
ben j'ai appris que je vais virer non
pas du tout tu
vas tu vas partir et tu vas revenir
contct ou pas pour l'instant tu as des
contacts Pol
ah tuas des sans nous dire cont je peux
pas
dire quand on dit ça ça veut tout dire
je peux pas dire c'est qu'on peut dire
il a lu dans tes pensées pour qui c'est
pour vous pour moi allez
concentrez-vous cy mettez tout votre
influx tout votre
l'argentam non ve dire
avidis
c'est ça c'est ça complètement ça
l'argent sur la tête de ma mère j'ai
j'ai tiré le mon le mon monde le monde
et à chaque fois vous tirez des très
bonnes cartes franchement vous avez la
baraca
BAR faire attention quand même parce
que il y a des cartes il a ça c'est une
protection que vous avez sur vous vous
avez une protection divineé quoi qu'il
puisse vous arriver on vous
protège que voilà l'au-delà est
quelqu'un de très proche de alors je
vois un homme une personne
âgée arrière grand-père ou quelelque
chose comme ça quelqu'un qui vous
protège qui est auprès de vous et qui et
qui vous envoie il me dit qu'il vous
envoie des signes à certains moment mais
vous captez pas ces signes là il faut
être un petit peu plus réceptif rapport
à ça voilà non non mais tout simplement
euh il y a des signes il y a des signes
de toute façon est-ce que vous avez pas
l'impression de ressentir des fois à
certains moments comme quelqu'un
derrière vous ou quelqu'un qui
i qui vous envoie des ondes ou qui vous
suggèrent certaines choses c'est vrai
c'est vrai voilà on suggère des choses
c'est vrai voilà franchement c'est vrai
parce que en fin de compte quand on
tiire ce genre de carte on a
l'impression qu'on est guidé par
quelqu'un et vous savez on parle
vulgairement de l'ange gardien bah là
vous avez un ange gardien effectivement
et par contre à certains moment vous
pourriez vous dire j'ai fait telle chose
et j'ai fait t chose mais c'est marrant
j'ai l'impression que c'est pas moi qui
les ai fait ces chosesl c'est des choses
qu'on m'a dicté qu'on m'a donné et qui
m' trans vra tu as raison non c'est vrai
c'est fou l'élu c'est l'élu non mais je
te jure que c'est vrai tu des fois
l'impression qu'on me dit tu vois voilà
ça vient pas de vous ça vient d'autre
part ouais c'est ouf voilà c'est cette
protection avec cette personne âgée qui
est autour de vous voilà
euh ça c'est très bon ça ça beaucoup de
voyage beaucoup de déplacements beaucoup
de choses dans lequel vous allez aussi
bouger alors attention par contre à pas
vous blesser ah ouais a au padle non
c'est vrai ah ouais ouais des pieds vous
AZ des pieds des choses comme ça les
ouais bah ouais c'est vous avez déjà eu
des problèmes de ce côté-là bon alors
faut faire attention quand même faut se
protéger de ce côtél
voilà merci Le Pendu c'est ça c'est des
pied tu as raison faut que je fasse
attention tu as raison chffer j'ai senti
que ça tirait un peu et puis surtout
écoutez bien quand vous avez
l'impression qu'on vous donne des
messages qu'on vous transmet des choses
comme ça parce que il y a des des
révélations
importantes et cette personne qui dont
je parle elle vient vous voir dans les
rêves vous avez jamais rêvé de vos
arrières grands-parents ou vos
grands-parents donc il vont venir vous
voir dans les rêve pour vous transmettre
aussi des choses à travers ce genre de
chosesàt merci janid tu un amour il est
très fort il est très fort très
fort merci jeanier d'avoir été avec nous
dans la nuit de